overall the number of covet cases is
going down worldwide are we finally
getting the upper hand will the pandemic
soon be over
well not in china although beijing is
sticking to its strict zero covet policy
the number of infections there is rising
welcome to a new covert 19 special
among other things we have a report from
shanghai where entire city zones are
still in lockdown and millions of people
are not allowed to leave their homes
also in the show living with a risk
factor more than a million americans
have died of covet 19 in the last two
years almost 40 percent of them were
diabetics
but first we head to the uk and to gina
and her little daughter
the mother caught covert 19 during
pregnancy her baby had to be delivered
prematurely
we see how gina lives with the trauma
and how she's plunging into new
adventures
[Music]
15 month old bonnie is a happy healthy
cheeky baby it's a testament to mum
gina's remarkable strength after her
battle with covid19
in february last year gina began
suffering severe symptoms while pregnant
and was forced to deliver bonnie
prematurely i
couldn't breathe i felt like it was i
was drowning that's the only way i can
explain it i remember early i was in the
morning texting all of my immediate
family telling them i loved them because
i didn't think i was going to wake up
and in the morning they come in and
pretty much said right we're whizzing
you down straight away you've got to be
it's got to be done today there was me
being ventilated
gina was so unwell doctors told her a
c-section was the only way to save both
her and her daughter
i felt sad felt angry
i felt so scared
my husband couldn't be there
no one was there
they just held held her up so i could
see whether she was a boy or a girl
and then that was it she was whizzed
away and i didn't see her for 14 days
and that was of her the first time i got
to see her face properly in the
photograph bonnie was delivered at just
30 weeks it was sent to me in a little
brown envelope so that was how i saw her
one
midwife in particular i just held my
hands out to her because i knew she was
the one that was dabbing my forehead
because i wanted to hug her
he couldn't
couldn't touch anyone it was something
out of a sire fire movie because um
like all the consultants and that they
had these great big like masks on with
tubes coming around into oxygen tanks
and it was so surreal so surreal this
was me meeting her for the first time
during her pregnancy gina was advised
against vaccination
pregnant women were not included in
clinical trials and data was limited
expectant mothers were not officially
advised to get the vaccine in the uk
until april last year my husband and her
for the first time as well health
officials now say women like gina were
let down
i think pregnant women have had a lot of
mixed messaging through the pandemic so
originally they were said oh it's all
fine don't worry you know it doesn't
seem to affect the pregnancy at all
and then it became oh you're within a
vulnerable group so take extra special
care but don't get vaccinated until we
have the first safety data from the
vaccines coming out saying actually you
can get vaccinated this is the head of
the baby here
experts say studies now make a clear
case for vaccination in pregnancy
the latest national data shows almost
all pregnant women hospitalized with
covert 19 are unvaccinated
and the government's running a campaign
to boost vaccine rates
we know that the vaccine does not cause
miscarriage does not cause starbursts
does not increase the risk of premature
births and therefore now we are
confident to uh recommend the vaccine to
pregnant women it's it is true that the
best way to protect
um the pregnant woman
and her baby is to get the carbon
vaccine
the risks of covert on pregnancy are
also clear
professor aris papa giorgio is the
co-author of a major global study which
documented how covert increases risks
for both mother and baby
in part he says because expectant
mother's immune systems are weaker it is
clear that covet during pregnancy
increases
the chances of premature birth increases
the chances of blood pressure in mums
and through the process of premature
birth also causes significant effects on
the baby as well as a risk of stillbirth
to the baby
although covert restrictions in the uk
were lifted after the emergence of
omicron risks for pregnant women remain
aris is now co-authoring another major
global study researching the effects of
newer variants on expectant mothers and
newborns
with less known about their impact
omicron seems to be on the face of it
less severe but we need to be a little
bit cautious because
when in the population lots of people
have been vaccinated or had the
condition and therefore have antibodies
sometimes it can appear that
the virus is less severe just because
lots of people have immunity
but for those people who are not immune
it may be that the virus still has
a significant impact there's a bunny in
the car with us for gina the trauma of
her battle with covert lingers
but today she and bonnie are the lucky
ones
gina's raising money for the neonatal
unit which cared for bonnie it's her way
of giving back to the team who may well
have saved her and her daughter's life
dw science correspondent derek williams
keeps on top of the latest scientific
research
today he answers the question
[Music]
are there risk factors that make you
more likely to contract long covet
as you can probably guess
this kind of research is just super
complicated to carry out
not least
because the term long covet doesn't
describe a straightforward condition but
a wide range of complaints that are all
still generally lumped together
under the medical term um post-acute
sequelae of covid19 or
pasc
but we're slowly starting to untangle
what risk factors seem to be linked
most often to it let's start with some
straightforward aspects
some studies indicate that women are at
higher risk of past especially
40 to 60 year olds
in general middle-aged people and the
elderly appear to be more affected by it
than younger people are and the evidence
has also piled up that if you're not
fully vaccinated then your chances of
developing past
after catching the disease are higher
now on to the more complicated stuff
a recent study involving hundreds of
test subjects and over 70 researchers
worldwide
came to the cautious conclusion that at
least four other factors could be
playing roles
in the development of pasc
the one that stuck out most was the
presence of what are called auto
antibodies which are
antibodies produced by the immune system
that
attack the body's tissues by mistake um
long coveted sufferers often seem to
make
auto antibodies very early on
in the course of their infections um
a second contributing factor could be
heavy viral load during an infection
with sauroscopy ii
perhaps
unsurprisingly people in the study who
for whatever reason had high levels of
the coronavirus in their bodies while
they were actively ill
they seemed more likely to go on to
develop past
the third factor that appeared linked to
long-coded symptoms was
the reactivation in the body of another
pathogen called
the epstein-barr virus which causes the
disease
mononucleosis also known as
glandular fever
now nearly all of us are infected with
this extremely common virus as kids
or young adults but
even after we shake off the symptoms
the epstein-barr virus doesn't disappear
but instead goes into a kind of
hibernation in your body and it can
reactivate again
later in life
that flare-up also seems to regularly
happen in some
past sufferers
and finally
the fourth factor linked to long covert
that the scientists identified was a
common comorbidity
those who have type 2 diabetes also
seemed more likely to develop past in
the wake of a covet 19 infection
[Music]
experts have found that one thing in
particular that can lead to a severe
case of covert 19 is diabetes
dw correspondent innes paul focuses on
the people living with diabetes the
numbers are shocking
[Music]
over a million people in the united
states lost their lives to the kovit 19
pandemic in the last two years
almost 40 percent of these were patients
with diabetes working as a nurse i saw a
lot of people lose their lives from
comorbidities and covid and with
diabetes it comes with you know kidney
failure kidney disease
and that plays a big factor as well is
on top of being sick
insulin prices are tough right now you
know people are rationing insulin in
order to just to get by because they
can't afford it so a lot of people are
unfortunately losing their lives from
not having the correct amount of insulin
but amy knows this better than most
because she was diagnosed with diabetes
at a very young age as a seven-year-old
you always want to fit in you want to be
the same as every other kid you want to
go outside and play sports and play
recess at school
and i was sometimes taken away from that
if my blood sugar was low i kind of had
to sit on the sidelines and eat a snack
to get my blood sugar up
if my blood sugar was high i had to go
to the nurse's office and take insulin
so i was kind of taken away from those
normal activities that
a normal seven-year-old would
participate in
there is some stigma towards people who
have diabetes that having this disease
is somehow their own fault
something that dr rodriguez fights
through his diabetes summer camp
many children don't have a schoolmate
or a friend that has type 1 diabetes
and it can make them feel very isolated
to be able to be at a camp in some cases
with 100 or more children
that all get up in the morning they test
their blood sugar or they're using a
continuous glucose monitor they're
counting their carbohydrates they're
dosing their insulin and all of that and
and for them to realize that they aren't
the only individual diabetes i think is
tremendously empowering
to understand how to empower the people
it's also crucial to understand the core
of the disease
diabetes is a complicated disease
we have some people who
are born with a predisposition for
type 1 diabetes
we have folks who
may have type 2 diabetes and
may be at risk because of
the environments that they live in
you know their social economical status
their education level
all this puts people with diabetes at a
very dangerous intersection with covet
covert 19 has had a an impact on all of
us
this virus this infection just
exacerbated their condition and also put
them at severe risk for complicate
complications from the virus itself
i've learned that
we need to put aside all of our biases
and just
be human beings again
dr rodriguez from the florida diabetes
camp has some advice
so specifically for children i would say
and their parents honest obviously
um
learn everything you can
learn everything you can surround
yourself with supportive individuals
and
don't let diabetes limit your
aspirations
so far over 6 million people have died
from the coronavirus every day thousands
more around the world are added to that
long list
what makes the virus so dangerous is
that it affects many different organs
dw reporter stephanie tsobu looks into
the latest research
[Music]
since the start of the pandemic
scientists have been describing sars
cov2 as a multi-organ aggressor the
virus can be found not only in the lungs
but in many other organs of the human
body
and now international studies have been
reporting new findings
more than 400 people who had been
infected with the coronavirus sometime
earlier were examined at germany's
university medical center hamburg
eppendorf or uke
we've examined people with mild and
moderate cases who had not gone to the
hospital and interestingly and
surprisingly we found evidence of mild
functional impairment of the heart
kidneys and lungs six months later
lung volume was reduced by a total of up
to three percent compared with a control
group
heart examinations showed an average
reduction of pumping strength by one to
two percent
kidneys filtering function a two percent
reduction
we assume that most of these organ
dysfunctions are completely reversible
however lasting minimal organ
limitations cannot be ruled out in some
patients especially those with severe
coronavirus cases
these are things that we need to examine
more closely in future longer-term
studies
[Music]
in other parts of the body such as blood
vessels the effects of even mild cases
of coronavirus infection are more
apparent
it's worth noting that larger ongoing
studies which have followed 150 000
patients for up to 12 months after their
covet 19 cases have shown that it can
significantly more often lead to
cardiovascular disease such as heart
attacks strokes thrombosis and
thromboembolic events
and that is indeed worrying
the coronavirus can also infect the
liver directly and lead to inflammation
and altered metabolic processes as
another uke study found
the brain can also be affected by a
coronavirus infection
smell and taste disorders are a known
and common symptom
the vagus nerve originates in the brain
from there it leads to the abdomen it's
connected to the heart lung intestines
and muscles and it controls heartbeat
breathing and digestion if sars cov2
damages the vagus nerve's function this
can lead to diarrhea rapid heartbeat
dizziness difficulty swallowing as well
as a drop in blood pressure
the pandemic has had some positive
consequences though since fewer people
suffered infections in general fewer
antibiotics were prescribed in germany
fewer than at any time since their
invention
dw reporter christina kufner asks if
this new development can be sustained
[Music]
guten tag from stilfred hello mr von
stilfried nice you could join us today
during the covid pandemic there has been
a drop in the amount of antibiotics
being prescribed a significant drop
could you explain why that might be
yes we've been seeing a decline in the
use of antibiotics in germany for years
now
germany is in any case in the bottom
third internationally and in europe when
it comes to using antibiotics
and has dropped even further during the
pandemics
does that mean that far too many were
prescribed in the past
of course in the last few years we've
become particularly conscious of the
fact that every single prescription is
potentially increasing the risk of
resistance
and of course it has something to do
with public awareness
if patients insist on receiving
antibiotics
they'll probably always be able to find
a doctor
my pleasure
in shanghai there were reports of people
screaming out of their windows at night
because they couldn't get enough to eat
this film that can no longer be seen in
china because beijing's online senses
deleted it shows a compilation of
telephone calls impressions and recorded
conversations in cordoned off districts
of shanghai
to combat the outbreak authorities are
instead administering herbal remedies
that are useless against covert 19 and
also harmful to health
still china is sticking to its strict
zero covert policy
shanghai has been in lockdown for a
month
it's not the first time traditional
chinese medicine or tcm has been used in
china's battle against covet 19 but its
distribution among people in shanghai
has been unprecedented
millions of batches of the homeopathic
capsule lianghor chinguin were handed
out to people under lockdown this month
zoe zhong says she and her four
flatmates received six boxes actually we
don't take it because
uh from the social media
that i followed it's not for like curing
your symptoms it's not preventing you
from the covet itself either lianghoa
chinguin's ingredients include
honeysuckle licorice root and other
herbs
tcm practitioners say it can help
suppress fever and sore throat but
health experts warn it's not an
alternative to vaccines
a leading chinese neurologist recently
hit out at the promotion of lianhua
chinguan he questioned why it received
delivery priority in shanghai when many
people under lockdown were struggling
with access to food we think that
the government should focus more on the
basic needs for the people
reports have also linked china's health
tsar zhong nanshan with the maker of the
pill healing pharmaceutical
john guides china's covet 19 policy as
head of the national health commission
he's said to have received funding from
e-link for his own medical foundation
and also signed a cooperation agreement
with the company
but beijing's also strongly backed the
tcm industry worth some 60 billion a
year according to the world health
organization the promotion of this this
kind of medical market is something
that's
certainly being encouraged the idea
being that if this
industry can be developed to a certain
level of maturity where uh
some very highly effective drugs are
developed
[Music]
then you know these these can become
part of the more mainstream mix of
different types of treatments not only
domestically but also internationally
the debate over the use of tcm has even
taken on a nationalistic tone people
criticizing it have been accused of
betraying china politics here seem to
once again be trumping scientific
efforts to beat covet 19.
the omicron variant is a problem for
china's zero covert strategy
in the spring hong kong had the world's
highest death rate among coronavirus
patients
now for the time being the wave seems to
have lost strength in the metropolis
[Music]
a hong kong travel agency struggles to
survive by turning itself into a grocery
instead of trips they sell food from
overseas
many others are shuttered because of the
pandemic border closure has made
traveling almost impossible for over two
years however the airport's departure
terminal is getting busier since the
beginning of this year hong kong's net
outflow has peaked at about 165
000 in april over five times the total
number of last year many are foreign
talents like john wood who left with his
business after eight years in hong kong
i want to be able to have my son where
he has the freedom to do simple things
like go to the beach or walk around
outdoors without a mask on and as a
global philanthropist i want to have the
freedom to travel around the world and
raise my seed funding and so for me hong
kong went from one of the most open
exciting cities in the world to being
this thing that is closed
and petrified where the government's
policies seem to change willy-nilly
the final straw is hong kong's adherence
to china's syracuse policy prompting the
toughest measures ever amid the omigran
outbreak not only individuals are voting
with their feet but also companies
companies are have significant problems
to refill positions to attract talent to
hong kong across industries it's even
reaching as far as financial services
industry which has usually been
perceived as the most resilient part of
it
in the latest survey released by the
european chamber of commerce about half
of the european companies in hong kong
plan to relocate in the coming year only
17 will firmly stay
hong kong is actually a popular base for
reaching the headquarters of foreign
businesses the exit of express comes on
top of the local brain drain triggered
by political upheavals and a sweeping
national security law when you wake up
every morning and see that journalists
are being arrested
um that
some newspaper publishers are being
arrested that there's no more freedom of
assembly no more freedom of speech that
hits me pretty hard you can't subject to
city state to all this solitude if you
do the the the cultural dna and the
intellectual dna dies a slow death
iata a global allied body said hong kong
has been effectively off the map as an
aviation hub flight spans and compulsory
hotel quarantine have been slightly
blessed after backlash starting from may
visitors can enter hong kong for the
first time in over two years it's a long
awaited first step but far from enough
for foreign businesses as they call for
a clear roadmap for food opening up
companies have to search for alternate
super connectors
tokyo hong kong will not lose its status
with regards to mainland china
we'll have to see
hong kong has always recovered from
crisis over decades but this time there
is no guarantee
that's it for this week's covet 19
special
we hope you can join us again next week
goodbye and stay healthy
[Music]
you